what is
awareness awareness is a fascinating
thing is it's it can be very similar if
for example you
meditate that you you realize that when
you meditate that you become aware of
how the mind is
working right especially if you have
your eyes
close you begin to feel the activity in
your brain and meditation is to quiet
that activity or to stop it in some way
to pause in Alexander it has something
to do with hyperactivity that you know
we're uncomfortable when we
stop people some people feel that they
need to do something
always in order to
be but uh that's what you learn you
learn to be uh comfortable with with
just stopping or pausing activity
habitual
activity and
to understand what it is to
be in your
body and uh and that's that's the
awareness and the awareness also helps
you to feel this relationship between
your head and your spine your whole body
and what you're doing with it and it if
you are tensing too much or uh holding
yourself or interfering with your breath
all of this comes
forward and uh the process of teaching
is helping
someone allowing that natural
coordination that we all had as children
to come back I mean I think we all know
what freedom is we had it when we were
we came into this world but gradually we
lose it as we you know as we go and and
Advance into our
lives luckily luckily actors can be
children all their
lives so it's a wonderful thing and as
time has gone on you know you started in
1969 with the Alexander technique have
you noticed that the ability to just be
it's actually not in fashion anymore
maybe it's come back but we're we're so
dialed and we've got to multitask and
have a side hustle and do all these
different things that it's almost seems
like it's out of fashion uh absolutely
it it not only is out of fashion but uh
we are rewarded if we're incredibly busy
you see so uh being very busy and and um
multitasking is
rewarded by people and um but the
difference in in acting is that the
actor has to be able
to
express a certain kind of clarity of
thought and a a connectivity with their
emotions especially also uh with the
intention of the play or the movie you
have to understand and know where you're
going and if you are too busy in your
body
that will never come through so the
actors that I work with they're at at a
level that uh they have
to uh be able to function at a higher
level and so they appreciate so much
what Alexander does you know um I just
did worked on a film that uh there was a
prosthetic a body prosthetic with um
these creatures and and it all was
moving you know so what what happened
was that we not only did the actor have
to have an awareness but also the disc
an uncomfortable feeling of these
Prosthetics and and still act and still
be the character you know so there's so
many challenges for the actor in terms
of um having an awareness that is way
higher than every day life you know do
you think it varies from theater actor
to television to an independent film
where time is very short or it's the
same across the board well there there's
something that is the same everybody has
to do certain work you know uh certain
preparations the level of How It's
respected is a little different if
you're in a very lowbudget
filmm it's faster because it costs so
much money and they they don't have as
much time but even then even then
usually uh I prepare the actors not
necessarily onet but I prepare them so
they can do it on their own and be
independent and and and do it and apply
it uh for that situation but then if I
have two or three months of preparation
in a big budget
film and and if they want to bring me in
to just remind them on set I I will do
that I will do that um so yeah there's
different
levels and different problems every film
is a different problem that's part of
the fun uh my job is living so many
different lives because I not only do I
have to research the character myself
but I I get to live it with them and the
actors we get so
close and it's so much much fun to be
able to have so many lives can awareness
be cultivated or developed absolutely
absolutely and and I always tell people
not to rush it because if you're uh we
have a term called end
gaining that if you're trying to get the
end of uh of a thing like Consciousness
or or awareness you're you know you're
uh it goes against the whole
process you need to take time you need
to take time and uh you do a little bit
of it every day I tell people uh
sprinkle your day with it do a little
bit in the morning do a little
bit between uh you know during
lunch and then when you get back home do
some more so the thing is it it
gradually it can be even in
integrated while you're
working can you give an example because
I want to be able to do things like this
but in La you can't just stop and you
know oh I'm going to be at the market
and taking the beauty you know there's
going to be someone for example for
example I'm using it right now so uh I
know that I'm on the spot and and and
you're expecting some form of
information to come out of me me and as
I'm doing that part of my nervous system
is with my own body so I'm not I'm not
abandoning my my instrument now I I can
do this because I've done it so
much that I can literally take care of
myself as I'm speaking to you and if
things were if I would feel that I was
losing my connection to my diaphragm
or I was beginning to tense my legs a
little bit too much I I might be able to
let it go without taking away from this
from the
interview and that could be true for a
circus performer uh and I've worked with
a Cirus Cay many times and uh they need
to balance while they're doing their
numbers right and of course in the in
the process they say oh T seen too much
I'm gonna
fall it's the same thing and there's an
audience around them and there's an
audience and actually can be very
exciting for the audience it can be very
exciting to see that kind of balancing
rebalancing you know suspense right the
possibility of failing but
not